hey everyone it's a registered nurse
Arion calm and in this video I want to
be going over part two of heart failure
this video is part of a cardiovascular
NCLEX review series that I want to be
covering and in the previous video I
covered part 1 of heart failure and I
talked about the path of heart failure
the signs and symptoms the different
types and things like that so if you
haven't watched that video be sure to
check that out because that video builds
upon this video and a card should be
popping up so you can access that so
what I'm going to do in this video is
I'm going to be covering the nursing
interventions and the medications given
specifically in heart failure because
that is really what the ink let's
examine your nursing lecture exams like
to hit on because as the nurse you need
to know what your role is you need to
know how to educate the patient and
those common side effects of those
medications you'll be giving in heart
failure and then after you watch this
lecture be sure to go to my website
register nurse orange calm and take the
free NCLEX quiz that will test you on
heart failure and a card should be
popping up so you can access that so
let's get started first let's recap and
talk about what is heart failure heart
failure is where the heart is too weak
to pump efficiently so it can't properly
give your body the cardiac output it
needs to maintain the metabolic needs so
you get some major issues going on and
remember from the other video your left
side of your heart or your right side of
the heart can be affected or you can
have both so remember with left-sided
heart failure you're going to get the
pulmonary symptoms and with right-sided
heart failure you're going to get those
peripheral symptoms and the most common
type of heart failure is left-sided and
it can cause right-sided heart failure
so keep those things in mind whenever
we're talking about medications and
things like that so what are the nursing
or ventricles cover that first why is
your role as a nurse in a nutshell what
you're going to be doing is you're going
to be assessing that patient
educating that patient and administering
medication so first let's talk about
this sesang part what are you going to
be doing okay as a nurse you are going
to be assessing assessing their symptoms
how are their symptoms are they
presenting worse than before like if
they're in right-sided heart failure how
is that peripheral swelling is it going
down because chances are there's no male
medications are they responding
appropriately to that are they getting
worse left side remember you get those
pulmonary issues is the patient
breathing better is there less crackles
how are they doing with that next you're
going to be assessing the patient's
responsiveness to those medications
medications such as digoxin you've got
to watch that heart rate because it can
slow the heart rate down beta blockers
things like that so you want to have
them on continuous monitoring or be
checking their vital signs often
watching their blood pressure because
they're going to be on ACE inhibitors
ARBs or vasodilators and that really
messes with the blood pressure and plus
your shifting fluids out a lot either
and fluid overload and you're getting
rid of flutes because they're at risk
for orthostatic hypotension and you're
going to be monitoring their volume
status because we're trying to diurese
them trying to remove that fluid so
they're going to be on diuretics chances
arm the physician will order a Foley
catheter because a lot of times these
patients come in there and fluid
overload they're going to be started on
IV may be loop diuretics like lasix it's
very strong diuretic especially going
the intravenous route so they may need a
Foley to help drain all that urine
that's going to be coming out because
getting up and going to the bathroom
will wear them out because they're
already the respiratory system is
already compromised and just going back
and forth to the bathroom puts a lot of
strain on them and you're going to be
monitoring and assessing those daily
weights every morning you're going to
get them up on a scale or use the bed
scale and you want to monitor that
weight because it's very important how
much weight they're losing or possibly
gaining then you're going to monitor and
look at those labs specifically you
really want to watch
levels because a lot of the medications
given in heart failure can cause
hypokalemia or hyperkalemia
for instance lasix lasix is a diuretic
that wastes potassium so you really go
to monitor that lasix level and
especially if they're on digoxin because
if you have low potassium that can
increase the chances of digoxin toxicity
hyperkalemia medications that can cause
that that are sometimes prescribing
heart failure or like those potassium
sparing diuretics that actually do the
opposite of loop diuretics they keep
potassium like al doc dome and ACE
inhibitors and ARBs they can increase
potassium so if you have a patient on an
ACE inhibitor and a lactone they are a
major risk for hyperkalemia so you have
to tell the patient's watch their
potassium intake also you're going to be
assessing and making sure they are
following their cardiac diet and their
fluid restriction diet a lot of patients
have issues with this because especially
the fluid restriction diet normally they
can only have about two liters of fluid
of day so you have to constantly monitor
what they're having for breakfast for
lunch and dinner and in between make
sure they're not cheating on that diet
because we're getting rid of that extra
fluid and we don't want to just be
putting it back in then we're going to
assess the edema in the legs that goes
back to the patient's responsiveness
helping keep those legs elevated
whenever they're in bed will help
promote returning that extra fluid back
into the vascular system hopefully being
excreted through the kidneys and keeping
them in high fowlers position to help
with respiratory that position setting
up riot helps the lungs expand and helps
decrease this vm next safety this is a
big issue with your heart failure
patients because number one chances are
they're going to be on some vasodilators
or some other blood pressure medicine
and and the body whenever they shift
positions may be lying in the bed they
get up they can get really dizzy
and they're at risk for falling so you
want to make sure you monitor them for
that and the extra swelling and the legs
and the feet make it really hard to walk
and put the feet on the ground and it
can leave
to them falling okay now educating this
is a big piece so remember this stuff
write it down because as the nurse we
want to educate our patients with heart
failure and regardless if you're not
working on a cardiac unit maybe you're
going to work on ortho your chances are
you're going to get patients with heart
failure because this affects a lot of
patients so our goal with educating is
that we want to prevent readmission this
disease process causes a lot of
readmissions for the hospital and we
want to prevent see a heart failure
exacerbation so what you want to teach
your patients is the following follow a
low sodium diet guidelines are no more
than 2 grams per day sometimes 3 so no
more than 2 to 3 grams of sodium per day
in your diet what are the hidden salts
like in canned foods your sandwich me
your frozen meals things like that that
you wouldn't normally think has a lot of
sodium in but do it in soft drinks next
fluid restriction the doctor wants them
on fluid restriction they need to make
sure they monitor how much they drink a
day because some of these medications
can make you thirsty so no more than 2
liters a day of fluid vaccinations make
sure that they are they need to be aware
that they need to get an annual flu
vaccine and that they're up to date on
their pneumonia vaccine because
illnesses can exact exacerbate heart
failure because it stresses the heart
out when a patient gets sick next
aerobic exercises that's like your
cardiovascular exercise they need to do
light to moderate exercise to keep that
muscle nice and strong and do that as
tolerated once there's symptoms symptoms
start dissipating next daily weights it
is so important that they weigh
themselves every day because it is an
early sign of c-h-s heart failure
exacerbation if they're gaining weight
so the guideline is if they're weighing
themselves make sure they're writing
them down and they need to notify their
doctor if they're gaining any more than
2 to 3 pounds per day or 5 pounds per
we that is signalling hey you're
starting to retain fluid something's
going on let's go to the doctor and
maybe they can prescribe some more
diuretics so I don't have to go to the
hospital in readmit it so daily rates
very important next compliance with
medications a lot of times especially
working as a nurse I have just seen
where patients have quit taking their
medicines maybe they couldn't afford
their medicine so they quit taking them
and this sent them into heart failure
exacerbation so very important they take
those medicines next smoking cessation
quit smoking very bad with the heart
causes vasoconstriction hard on the
heart and limiting alcohol consumption
next i'm teach your patient those early
signs and symptoms we just talked about
the weight gain also if they notice that
all of a sudden they can't tolerate
normal activities that they were doing
like just getting up and going into the
kitchen they know so there's trying to
get a little short of breath or at night
whenever they're trying to sleep that
they have to put a couple pillows behind
them to sleep better look which is
called ortho P neum those are some
warning signs that hey I may be going
into heart failure exacerbation now
let's look at the medications for heart
failure when you're studying these
medications for the NCLEX or for your
nursing lecture exams make sure you know
the drug categories that are given in
heart failure and what drugs are
included in that category and how they
work on the body the pharmacodynamics
and their side effects and patient
education very important key points you
want to remember okay to help you
remember the drug categories that are
given in heart failure remember this
mnemonic always administer drugs before
a ventricle die in heart failure our
issue is with the ventricles they are
either not pumping they're not
contracting properly or they're too
stiff so they're not filling properly so
we want to make this heart work easier
especially these ventricles so that
emmonak should help you remember those
drugs that are included so the first a
ACE inhibitors ACE inhibitor stands for
angiotensin
Burdine enzyme and this is usually the
first line of treatment in patients with
heart failure and it's sometimes
prescribed with a beta blocker which
we'll go over a little bit later these
drugs tend to end in PR IL and one
example of a ACE inhibitor is lisinopril
and how this drug works is that it
blocks the conversion of Enzi
angiotensin one to angiotensin 2 so you
don't have the conversion of angiotensin
one go to angiotensin 2 and what does
what how does that work well we know
whatever angiotensin 2 works it causes
vasoconstriction but it's not allowed to
do that so in turn you're going to get
vasodilation which is going to decrease
the blood pressure and you're going to
get kidney excretion of sodium think
back whenever an Ziya angiotensin is
being blocked what's going to happen is
this going to cause your old Ostrom
levels to decrease what does aldosterone
do aldosterone whenever it's being
decreased it will cause your kidneys to
keep the tascam but excrete sodium which
is what we want in heart failure we're
trying to get rid of all that extra
sodium and fluid in the body and this
drug is helping us get rid of that extra
sodium however because it's doing that
it's going to keep the potassium the get
rid of the sodium we have to watch out
for side effects of hyperkalemia high
potassium levels and for some reason
with this drug these patients can
develop a nagging dry cough and I have
seen this as a nurse it's for real and
it really does happen they will
literally call every three to four
minutes just this just over and over and
over and it drives them crazy and the
jobs with people around them crazy so
some people can't tolerate this drug
next drug ARBs they if the patient
cannot tolerate an ACE inhibitor they'll
be placed on an ARB and how do arms work
arm stands for angiotensin ii
after blockers so they're a little bit
similar so let's look ok these like I
said are used in place of ACE inhibitors
they in in Sartain sa RTA n type of drug
of this is losartan can they work by
blocking angiotensin ii receptors so
instead of blocking the conversion of
angiotensin one angiotensin ii like the
ACE inhibitors did this works by just
blocking the receptor so again you're
going to get some phase out dilation and
it's going to have the same effects on
the body as your ACE inhibitors because
you're going to have that decrease
aldosterone and the patient's going to
keep potassium but excrete sodium
however a side effect with this is
hyperkalemia just like with ACE
inhibitors but they will not get that
dry hacking cough okay our other driver
diuretics d these either patient will be
prescribed on loop diuretics or
potassium sparing diuretics and these
diuretics are used in a combination with
these ACE inhibitors or an ARB they're
used together and what your diuretics do
is it helps your body get rid of that
water and that sodium retention because
in heart failure what we're doing is
we're taking all this water we got edema
everywhere retaining sodium so it helps
us to excrete that decrease that edema
and it helps the heart pump easier
because it doesn't have all that fluid
volume in its chambers trying to pump so
it's getting rid of that however a side
effect of this is that this patient will
urinate a lot so as a nurse you want to
be monitoring that your an output very
very closely and you want to monitor
their bu in and create and making sure
we're not die erasing them too much and
put too much strain on those kidneys
okay an example of a loop diuretic is
lasix member with lasix or live
diuretics they waste potassium so before
you get potassium I mean before you give
lasix check those potassium levels to
make sure that they're good because you
go in and give some lasix number tossing
levels already too you're going to
bottom that out even more saying a lot
of times for physicians will prescribe
potassium supplements along with lasix
and potassium sparing drugs a drug al
and what things do they do opposite of
loop diuretics they keep potassium so
you have to watch out for educate the
patient not to consume foods that are
high in potassium and to especially
watch if your patient is on an ace or an
ARB because remember they keep potassium
and if they're taking a lactone you have
a double risk of increasing that
potassium level next beta-blockers how
do beta blockers work they work by
blocking the norepinephrine effects on
the heart muscles so norepinephrine will
naturally increase your heart rate so
we're going to block that from happening
so beta blockers are going to slow down
the heart rate they have a negative
inotropic effect which decreases my
cardio contraction hence a fancy word
for slow in the heart rate which will in
turn decrease your heart's workload
because it is overworked and heart
failure these drugs end in lol typical
ones used in heart failure or metoprolol
carbonyl and vis brawl now typically the
way that these beta blockers work they
slow down your heart
so they weaken the heart's contraction
so in some forms of heart failure
especially acute heart failure that
deals with systolic dysfunction you
don't initially want to use these beta
blockers because let's think back to the
other lecture what is systolic
ventricular dysfunction systolic that is
the squeezing phase of the heart so
there is an issue with this ventricle
being able to squeeze that blood out so
if we throw if this patient is an acute
systolic dysfunction we throw a beta
blocker on them it's going to weaken
that heart contraction even more and we
don't want to do that because we have a
contraction problem so it will sometimes
the beta blockers will be used in stable
systolic dysfunction and a lot of times
these beta blockers are prescribed with
ACE inhibitors or those ARBs in
combination now a lot of times beta
blockers are used
and despot a diastolic dysfunction heart
failure and what was been tricular
diastolic dysfunction that was where
remember diastole is the filling phase
of the heart the resting phase and
there's an issue with the ventricle
maybe it's too stiff and it doesn't feel
properly with all that blood it needs to
fill with but what a beta blocker can do
is slow down that heart rate let that
ventricle rest a little bit longer and
feel more with blood so it can squeeze
it out because it's squeezing mechanisms
GRA it's just the feeling so sometimes
it will be used to treat a ventricular
diastolic dysfunction now side effects
of your beta blockers remember this and
bradycardia so before you give a beta
blocker check the heart rate make sure
they're not too bright of kardec and it
can mask hypoglycemic signs and symptoms
in diabetics a lot of times a diabetic
knows when their Sugar's low because
they may get tachycardic hence you're
not going to get tachycardic with
bradycardia with beta blockers because
it slows the heart rate down or they can
get sweaty things like that and that
masks those symptoms so you need to your
diabetics fat and beta blockers can
cause respiratory issues so they're
typically not prescribed especially the
ones that aren't selected for patients
with COPD or asthma because it could
cause bronchoconstriction and whenever
the patients take these tell them not to
take them with any type of juices
especially grapefruit juice because it
can interfere with your body's
absorption of the beta blockers okay
next let's look at a for anticoagulants
these are not used in every patient with
heart failures so typically it's going
to be used in heart failure patients who
a lot of times heart failure and atrial
fibrillation go hand-in-hand and you
know with afib those atrium are just
quivering blood is pulling in there when
blood pools that's not good because a
clot can form can shoot through the
heart and we can have an embolism
so if patients in afib with heart
failure they may be started on
anticoagulant or they have a history of
blood clots or they have an ejection
in less than 35% we talk about we talked
about another video what ejection
fraction was and this is where your
heart is not squeezing all that blood
out properly so contraction isn't good
and if it's not squeezing all that blood
out that's normally going in there with
systolic dysfunction you're going to
have more blood pool in there so there's
a increased chance of developing a clot
and shooting it through the heart okay
next V for vaso dilators a lot of times
these are prescribed if a patient can't
tolerate an ACE inhibitor or an arm
because it worked by causing dilation
and um one drug which is an arterial
dilator is hydralazine and it's a lot of
time sometimes prescribed with a nitrite
called ice or dill and that is a venous
die later hydralazine is a specific drug
that acts specifically on your arteries
and I so deal is what acts on your vein
so what happens is that you get dilation
going on of those arteries and veins
what how does this work how does it
benefit the heart it decreases blood and
fluid going back to the heart because of
a card is already overloaded in heart
failure with all this blood and all this
food so we got all this nice donation
going on I know will decrease the amount
of fluid that's going back and the
workload that your heart has to undergo
however side effects with this are
hypotension because anytime you have
dilation going on the patient is at risk
for hypertension so you want to measure
that blood pressure make sure it's good
before you get it and they're at risk
for orthostatic hypotension so say your
patients on these medications they're
laying in bed they need to get up to go
to the bathroom you want to get them up
slowly and gradually because they can
get dizzy they can pass out and fall so
you want to watch safety issues with
that next d4 digoxin
how does digoxin work on the body I
would remember this for sure okay it has
a positive inotropic mechanism which
means that it has that the heart has an
increased ability to
humph stronger however it has a negative
chrono trophic mechanism that allows it
to beat slower so it's a win-win it
beats slower but it pumps more
efficiently so this allows the heart to
rest and pump more blood which is great
if you've had less than tricular
systolic dysfunction which is what this
drug is sometimes you sin however it's
not uses first-line treatment for heart
failure and it's going to be used
alongside with your ACE inhibitors or
your diuretics because digoxin can be a
nasty drug it has toxicity issues and if
a patient and has a low potassium level
goes into hypokalemia chassie level less
than 3.5 they can go into digoxin
toxicity so with this drug you want to
monitor the drug levels and I would
remember this a normal digoxin level is
0.5 to 2 nanograms per milliliter this
is where you want that patient to hang
out anything higher than 2 is bad
digoxin toxicity in signs and symptoms
of ditch talks is City classic I have
seen this this does happen and they'll
have nausea and vomiting and they'll
report some vision changes they may all
of a sudden start seeing some yellowish
green halos they can be braids of Kartik
as well and what would happen you notify
the physician immediately don't give
another dose of digoxin and the
physician will probably order the
antidote for digoxin which is digibind
very easy to remember it tells you what
it is digibind eigi be IND
matches digoxin that is the antidote for
that and whenever you are giving the
dachshund as a nurse you always want to
check that apical pulse and make sure
it's greater than 60 beats per minute
before giving the dose okay so that is a
review the part to review of heart
failure be sure to go to my website
register nurse orient calm and take that
free quiz and thank you so much for
watching and please consider subscribing
to this YouTube channel